[Music]
you have a a terrific uh show that you
do uh a talk show that's on the web and
i want to ask you about it because you
have a very unusual way of getting
guests on this yeah it's um uh i have
this website and company called soul
pancake and we have this new youtube
channel youtube slow pancake and i've
been doing a talk show called
metaphysical milkshake
and uh we don't have a fancy studio like
this with fancy audience members we we
do it in the back of my 1976 chevy van
so the whole show is taped in the back
of your van yeah it's in the back of my
van and you know we have uh frankly we
have a hard time getting guests so we
have to result to some very unorthodox
ways of obtaining guests for our show oh
let's take i think we have a clip of you
getting some guests they're pretty good
guys these days let's get them get in
the van chopra
move it
you want some candy
i got reese's peanut butter cups
[Music]
it works you've got to be very close to
a wall i lost it would you like to be on
my show
just say yes yeah sure i mean it just
surprised me yeah
oh i'll surprise you the answer
the answer is yes